so former officer derek chovin has been
remanded into custody he is now in jail
eventually
he will appeal his case this was always
a case where if chauvin was convicted of
anything it was clear that he was going
to appeal
generally speaking criminal appeals have
a very very low rate of actually
changing the outcome at trial
it can happen but it's pretty rare but
one thing that will definitely not
happen is this case will not go before
the united states supreme court people
talk about
taking things all the way to the supreme
court all the time that the supreme
court doesn't really intervene number
one in state cases
that much and number two they don't
really intervene when it's just an
application of facts to the law all of
the legal standards that we're at issue
in the chauvin trial
are pretty well cut and dry so there's
nothing for the u.s supreme court to
intervene on it's possible that the
minnesota supreme court might weigh in
on the murder 3 charge that was brought
here but that's not likely to have much
of an effect because shelvin was
convicted of murder 2. so while you
might be seeing this in court you will
not be seeing this in the u.s supreme
court